so you're now a fan favorite of the show
how does that feel I mean I think I'm a
favorite of some you're a fan favorite
everyone was very excited you were
coming there are people on the crew that
were like she's coming I was like oh my
gosh yeah I think what's nice about this
season is that everyone has somebody
different to kind of plug into we're all
pretty different like you know much more
diverse I think between age and
ethnicity and background and age I'm the
old one yeah yeah no one thinks about
that yeah I was like no one thinks old
when they look at you they just think
damn I'm not that cool yeah no that's
not what they're thinking are thinking
that wait did Andy Cohen have to
actually convince you to do it I mean
convince is a strong word we had to come
to Jesus so we knew each other prior um
and at the very end we were sort of
getting ready to sort of do the final
decision he and I spoke on the phone and
he said exactly he didn't want to
convince me he was like you have to make
the decision on your own because it's a
really vulnerable situation and anything
that you don't want people to know they
will know these fans are they're like
forensic scientists if any of you are
out there I know you I know you know
[Music]
[Applause]
everything thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home